[Music]
on this tuesday night manitoba's
alarming uptick in kobit 19 cases
what's fueling the spread there and why
targeted restrictions won't work
plus the quebec premier's latest plea we
must
remain very cautious and who's being
deployed to battle a crisis in long-term
care homes
a covig-19 vaccine trial suspended why
it's on pause and why experts say it
might be a good thing
crude reality for oil we saw in 2028
drop in demand the new prediction for
when demand for oil could peak
and what it will mean for alberta's
future and
there's an award-winning app for that
the teenage brains behind a program
helping people with dementia
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a warning for people not
getting the message about the spread of
covid19
despite repeated pleas to limit social
contacts canada's caseload is still
rising
and targeted restrictions in place now
could expand into more
widespread measures if cases keep
climbing take manitoba for example it
now has the second highest rate of
active cases in canada after quebec
that's per 100 000 people most
infections
are in winnipeg and the big problem
there
is the level of community transmission
people young and old
are getting covid19 in different parts
of the community and contact tracers
are struggling to keep up what we're
seeing here is increasing
community-based transmission
which makes it very difficult to take a
very targeted approach
here is the picture across the country
today there are 26 new cases in manitoba
saskatchewan has 34
and starting this friday the maximum
number of people allowed to gather in
private homes in saskatchewan will be
slashed from 30 to 15.
further west there are 220 new cases in
alberta
101 in bc new brunswick has six new
cases today there are 746 in ontario
and more than 800 in quebec there are
signs the situation in quebec may be
starting to plateau although the virus
is still spreading into new communities
three more regions were put into the
province's red zone today
the premier is pleading with people to
limit their social contacts
we'll have to live with the virus for
many months
and there's no magic recipe
we must avoid indoor gatherings
of more than 15 minutes mike lucatour
has more detail on
where we're at in this second wave and
what officials worry about
most from the start of the pandemic the
goal was always to crush the curve and
prevent hospitals from being overwhelmed
we did it once but the numbers are
climbing again as the second wave
ripples across the country
and its cause for concern in ontario all
of a sudden we saw
acute care beds increasing by 250
percent in the hospitals we're concerned
about the icu capacity
data collected from provincial health
authorities show a sobering trend in
hospitalizations particularly
in canada's two largest provinces
ontario's numbers are below quebec's
trend line but both
are on an uptick this is the time to
double down
on our efforts to stop the spread
that call for a collective response came
as the government responded to a
re-emerging
trend right now 66 long-term care
facilities in ontario
are dealing with outbreaks and since
january there's been a total
of 500 outbreaks instead of sending in
the army prime minister justin trudeau
said
the red cross will be deployed to a
number of homes
that will help with the immediate crisis
but trudeau admits long-term care
needs a long-term fix i don't think
there should be some regions of the
country that offer
better or worse protections to elders
than others i think that's why the time
has come for a conversation
between the federal government and the
provinces on harmonizing and
establishing
norms canada's top doctor agrees but
points out it's a provincial
jurisdiction that has both public
and private run homes adding to the
complexity
it's why a multi-layer approach is
needed which includes
rapid testing millions of rapid tests
will be sent to the provinces and
territories to be used in high-risk
or remote areas how they deploy within
specific jurisdictions is actually up to
the province and territories
um i believe that the agreed upon
approach
was more focused on per capita
allocation
and it's expected those tests will be
shipped to provinces and territories
within the next week michael couture
global news ottawa
a second human clinical trial of a
potential covit 19 vaccine has been
paused because one of the participants
developed an unexplained illness
the johnson and johnson vaccine
candidate is one of seven
potential vaccines now in phase three of
human clinical trials
all of them must pass this phase to
prove they are safe and effective in
humans
suspending a vaccine trial is not
unusual but
never has the world been watching this
process as closely or waiting
as anxiously eric sorenson explains what
we know
and don't know it is a setback for
johnson johnson
one person in its vaccine trial with an
unexplained illness
it's not uncommon especially in such a
huge trial with sixty thousand
participants
the company says it has temporarily
paused further dosing in all its trials
it's investigating whether the illness
is related to the vaccine
the patient could have received a
placebo and it says such illnesses
are an expected part of clinical studies
astrazeneca also paused its vaccine
trials temporarily
after two participants fell ill last
month one with serious spinal
inflammation
experts say it's a good sign that
vaccines are not being pushed out
hastily the public can know that there
is an independent data board that's
going to be looking at this
and we know in canada that health canada
is not going to authorize a vaccine that
is not safe for public youth
the whole world wants a vaccine but
there are concerns about safety being
compromised by politics
the u.s president wanted to announce a
vaccine before the u.s election
though he acknowledges now it may not be
approved on his timetable
i think we should have it before the
election but frankly the politics gets
involved and that's okay
they want to play their games it's going
to be right after the election still
the scale of the research worldwide is
astonishing
vaccine trials at different stages are
happening in laboratories from france to
the united states and from brazil to
germany
in all around 100 vaccines are being
developed
and human tests are underway on
volunteers from china to the uk
to australia more than 40 vaccines are
in clinical human trials
i don't think there's been anything of
this scale before another hopeful sign
180 countries have committed to the
world health organization's effort
to finance vaccines so countries rich
and poor will get them
it sets a good example for for believing
in
and trying to achieve equitable access
of vaccines
meantime canadian officials are
confident in the johnson johnson
evaluation
i'm sure people will resume the trial as
soon as they
are satisfied that patient safety isn't
compromised
covet 19 research is happening with
remarkable speed
as the world waits for a vaccine that
will both protect from the virus
and do no harm erik sorensen global news
toronto one of the many questions
scientists still have is whether you can
get covid19 more than once
the u.s now has a confirmed case of a
patient who was re-infected
and his second illness was worse than
the first the case published in the
lancet involves a 25-year-old man with
no
known immune disorders he tested
positive in april and recovered then
went on to have two negative tests and
48 days after that first positive test
he tested positive again researchers say
what is worrisome is his second illness
was worse than the first the man
required oxygen and ended up in the
hospital
he has since recovered again similar
cases have been reported in other
countries and the findings suggest
exposure to the virus may not guarantee
immunity but
much more research is needed ontario is
dealing with what's believed to be one
of the largest outbreaks at a fitness
center in canada
at least 61 cases are linked to a spin
studio
in hamilton 44 gym users and staff
members at spinco have tested positive
for the virus
17 cases of household spread have also
been identified
and public health officials warn up to
100 people may have been exposed
infectious disease experts consider it a
super spreader event
a loan case that triggered a chain of
infections ontario premier doug ford
says it's a reminder to be vigilant
no matter where you are we can't let our
guard down
but we're going to be there to support
all the gyms especially the small gyms
out there because it's difficult for
them how can your heart not break for
these people
and not not be there to support them
every which way we can
in a statement spinco says it's
devastated by the outbreak and that
contact tracing is now complete
health officials say the company
followed all safety protocols
alberta's government is making some big
cuts to that province's health care
system 11
000 public sector jobs will be
eliminated over the next three years
the bulk of them 9 700 positions will
come from areas such as
laundry housekeeping and laboratory work
which the government intends to
outsource to the private sector
at least 100 management jobs will also
be cut
the job reductions could begin as early
as next spring
the government estimates the changes
will save 600 million dollars annually
money it promises will be reinvested
into patient care
alberta is dealing with rising covet 19
case numbers the health minister vows
these changes
will not impact front line health care
workers
i can confidently say government's
direction is that there will be no job
losses
for nurses or front line clinical staff
any reductions must be managed through
vacant managers sorry vacant positions
and existing initiatives unions have
raised concerns in the past about plans
to reduce public sector staff calling
the cuts
ideological south of the border just
three weeks until a presidential
election and covet 19 cases keep
rising at least 37 states have had an
increase in cases in the last two weeks
some are setting new records president
trump has told americans not to let the
virus dominate them
but the fact is the pandemic is both a
personal and a political issue
for millions of americans jackson
proskow reports
months into the pandemic and these are
the worst days yet in many states
today's numbers show more
new positive cases more hospitalizations
and more deaths than we've had during
the entire pandemic
in the last week seven states have set
daily records for new cases
several are on the brink of running out
of hospital beds what may be the start
of the feared
fall wave if we do not work very hard to
push down the number of cases to the
lowest number possible we're going to
start paying for it
as it gets colder and people are indoors
[Music]
that grim reality is still being ignored
by president donald trump
who appeared maskless while tossing out
masks at a campaign rally in florida
before baselessly claiming that his own
fight with covid19 has left him immune
i went through it now they say i'm
immune i can feel i feel so powerful
i'll walk into that audience
i'll walk in there i'll kiss everyone in
that audience
there's no proof that long-term immunity
exists there is mounting evidence that
trump's risky rallies are spreading the
virus
more than a dozen people who attended
this event in minnesota have since
tested positive
his reckless personal conduct since his
diagnosis
has been unconscionable the longer
donald trump is president
the more reckless he seems to get
president trump is recovering from the
coronavirus
and so is america trump remains
undeterred and is now using the
words of his top infectious disease
expert made months ago
out of context in an attempt to rewrite
history
i can't imagine that anybody could be
doing more
three weeks before the election the
pandemic has become the defining issue
of the campaign
leading to incredible scenes as long
lines form for early voting
but there is still no sense of better
days ahead as the pandemic
threatens to shape daily life for months
to come
jackson prosko global news washington
chilling new information is emerging
about members of an anti-government
paramilitary group accused in that plot
to kidnap michigan's governor
the fbi testified at a federal detention
hearing today
saying the group also discussed
kidnapping virginia's governor
they were angry about the restrictions
he imposed to reduce the spread of
covid19
a spokesperson for governor ralph
northam says the fbi
alerted his security detail during the
investigation
and enhanced security measures were put
in place 13 men have been charged after
the fbi thwarted a suspected plot to
overthrow the michigan state government
attack the police and try to ignite a
civil war
a high school in ontario has launched an
investigation after a racist message
replaced what a student had written
next to his yearbook photo
seventeen-year-old joshua telemach says
the
entry he wrote paid tribute to his late
grandmother and that's what was supposed
to accompany his graduation photo but
when the yearbooks were distributed over
the weekend he discovered that message
was replaced with
a racist one that included a reference
to a gorilla
imagine you knowing that you wrote
something
and like you wanted to do something good
and it just got changed into something
negative and horrible
that's a huge form of bullying and no
person no no matter what age or anything
you are deserves to go through that
the school is asking students to return
those yearbooks and it's working with
the durham regional police service to
determine who is responsible
the principal says there will be
disciplinary action
the outlook for oil demand coming up new
projections paint an
uncertain future for alberta's oil patch
plus
record breaker the astonishing flight
that just landed one bird
in the history books
there was a stark picture painted today
by the international energy agency
it says the era of global demand for oil
will come to an
end in the next decade the agency
believes the pandemic is not just a
short-term shock but a long-lasting blow
to the industry
and that demand for oil will peak by
2030 as people and countries seek
lower emission ways of generating power
and that will have profound
consequences for oil-rich economies like
alberta
heather urex west has reaction from
there tonight
to say the last few years have been
bumpy for the alberta oil patch
is to put it mildly job losses have been
massive and the province is facing
record levels of debt
particularly for oil we saw in 2028
drop in demand for oil as people were
staying home not flying a huge drop
lifestyles are changing now a new
forecast from the international energy
agency
is suggesting that some of those changes
are not coming back
growth in global oil demand is set to
end within 10 years
but those growth projections have been
greatly impacted by covet 19.
pre-pandemic oil demand was set to rise
12 percent by 2030
that's now fallen to 9 percent but if
coveted 19 isn't brought under control
by next year
that forecast falls all the way to just
four percent growth
to a certain degree it's sort of a
confirmation of writings on the wall
uh that others have been pointing to for
some time
it means alberta's energy sector will
need to fight harder for fewer
opportunities
and that's something industry says
canada has not been successful with so
far
today we're losing investment to norway
to offshore brazil to the middle east
that competition isn't going to go away
and in a lower growth scenario
i think we need to be more ambitious
more aggressive alberta's government
says despite adjusted growth projections
the report
shows oil and gas demand is not
disappearing anytime
soon that said we also know that there's
new sources of energy coming into the
mix we brought forward a
natural gas strategy last week to focus
on hydrogen petrochemicals plastics
circular economy for plastics
geothermal we're looking at small
modular reactors
there is some hopeful news in the report
post pandemic oil prices are expected to
surge as the industry plays catch up
with global demand
but long term a massive shift has begun
leaving energy producing nations like
canada with few choices
make changes now or risk being left
behind
heather urex west global news calgary
no lines no problem ahead one tourist
who got a world heritage site all to
himself
it is not news that birds migrate of
course but the journey this one takes is
simply astonishing and it set a new
record
for non-stop flight a bartailed godwit
was tracked as it migrated from alaska
to new zealand
it flew up to 88 kilometers an hour and
it traveled over 12
000 kilometers in just 11 days without
stopping
to eat drink or sleep that beats the
previous record when a godwit was
tracked covering more than 11 000
kilometers in nine days
godwits weigh on average less than a
pound and scientists still don't fully
understand how they navigate over the
open water of the pacific ocean
well it took a pandemic to give one
adventurer the opportunity of a lifetime
peruvian tourism officials opened
machu picchu for the first time in seven
months just for this one japanese
tourist
jesse katayama arrived to see the famous
inca ruins on march 14th
but two days later peru went into
lockdown and the site was shut down
he stayed in the area though and local
tourism authorities
found out about his story and they
awarded his patients with
this pristine view of the site which
would normally be crowded with thousands
of visitors
machu picchu isn't expected to open to
larger number of tourists
until next month next the tech savvy
teens who developed a new haven for
dementia patients
with so many negative things happening
around the world it's always a plus when
we can shine a light on the people
making a positive difference
this story is about a group of teenage
girls from ireland who entered an
international tech competition
they created an app with a personal
connection and not only did they win the
top prize
it promises to improve the lives of
people living with dementia
mike drolet reports
when you give out an award virtually you
lose that element of excitement
but you have to think the us-based hosts
of the technovation awards felt the
earth move
when three nigerian irish girls from
drahida ireland
took home the top prize memory haven
[Applause]
that by the way is how it's done
celebrate when you win
apologize on national broadcaster rte
later
i'm pretty sure we'd start the neighbors
to be honest like probably got a couple
noise complaints
but yeah it was just unreal yeah it's
pretty unreal when you beat out 1500
apps created by students from 62
countries and when their mentor's mother
died from dementia they honored her by
creating
memory haven which acts as a surrogate
memory for patients
while keeping them connected with family
we created an app to promote the
independence of people living with
dementia
it was a runaway hit and the
overwhelming response was positive
but there's always a but the biggest
moment of their young lives
was also they say their first exposure
to racism
their mentor evelyn nemayo tried to
shield them from the hate
i remember the night after i saw it i
was just going through it i actually
cried
especially when i saw the monkey face
and
you know i i sorry i'm getting emotional
now because it just reminded me of that
time
it was hard for all of them but no one
was going to ruin what they had achieved
so they kept smiling and singing
knowing how they reacted would influence
girls as their mentor influenced them
and here's the best part leading tech
innovators like alyssa atkins
have taken notice i feel proud of them
not even knowing them but
you know certainly their journey hasn't
been easy and without having
ever met them i feel like i know they're
gritty and persistent
and it's so important to have more women
like them
and one more thing did i mention they're
still teenagers
micro leg global news toronto
love that and that is global national
for this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is douglas
provincial park in saskatchewan named
after late saskatchewan premier and
father of medicare tommy douglas
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye